So, you have to know where you are,
you have to know where you're going,
and then you have to fill
your own coding with that stuff
and start building the infrastructure
for the future.
Thomas Schindler,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm great.
It's my pleasure.
Thank you for inviting me.
Of course.
Where are you calling from?
I'm currently in Berlin.
The weather,
there weather's getting chilly here.
And we're looking forward
to hopping back to Costa Rica
because we tend to hop
between Berlin and Costa Rica.
Is that for a weather reasons?
Because of opposite seasons?
My wife is from Costa Rica.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Very, very nice.
Thomas, we only have 20 minutes.
Your journey is so fascinating.
And that, you know,
if you just look
at the things you're doing,
it almost looks like
it's exactly the journey
that are fitting for this show.
These nonlinear journeys
that are not just about
a specific profession
or a specific company,
but they are more holistically about
what is our purpose
and who are we as human beings.
And I'm not going to do
enough service to your journey
if I tried to give an outline myself.
But I'd love to hear from you
a little bit about
what are you excited about?
And maybe even take me back a few years
about the different things you've done.
And then I'd love to culminate also
in the most recent company, Delodi.
And the funny thing
that we talked about,
the Delodi or Delodi.
All right.
So, what I'm
always excited about
and what drives me
is trying to contribute
towards making the planet a good place.
And I say goods
intentionally.
And I borrow it from Isabel Allende,
who once pointed to the fact that:
an increment is, while necessary,
never an end.
We have to never forget that
we need to head towards a good state
and not towards a
suggest a better state.
And the way I like to bring this home is,
if you imagine
14,000 children
under the age of five dying every day
from preventable causes,
that would be better.
Because at the moment
it's 15,000, righ?
But it should be zero.
And that's good, right?
So, should never forget
where we're headed.
And I think that's crucial.
And having this big "why"
is absolutely critical.
And just yesterday,
my son, who's 11 years old surprised me
by finding
Simon Sinek's Golden Circle
all by himself
in preparation for a video
he intends to do
about some future issues.
Wow.
So, how does this "why"
integrate into the life cycle
of an entrepreneur, a leader?
I'd love to,
because this is something
that I'm personally passionate about
and in my own journey of understanding,
what are the types of things
that I want to be working on.
Things that,
and just yesterday
I was walking with somebody
in Tel Aviv, and we were talking about
what kind of company
do we want to build one day.
And we at least decide
that there's two things:
one, we have to be intentional
about what we want to achieve;
the second, it has to have
a positive social impact on the world.
But I'm still confused
what does that mean?
Yes,
I'm continuously confused
and I nurture my confusion
as well as my naive look on the world.
And I think,
these are two crucial elements
of trying to move
towards something meaningful.
And not becoming desperate
at the state of the world's,
not becoming frustrated
at the hardships that you go through
when you build something.
And I think this is deeply connected
with the question of,
what is the ultimate objective
you're after.
And if this is a lot bigger than you,
if this is a lot further out
than you could possibly achieve,
then you're probably on the right track.
Because what I learned
in building businesses,
all sorts of organizations
of the past more than 20 years,
is that,
if I don't align my current activities
with a larger goal,
larger than life allowed me to go,
I'm not never really sure
whether I'm doing the right thing.
And I can never really judge
whether
there is something
that has more impact
towards the goal I want to achieve.
And I have a very specific goal,
and it doesn't have to be
that everybody has to have
that same goal
of trying to contribute towards
making the planet a good place,
but you can also choose to have a goal
to maximize your personal
financial profit if you wish,
but you need to have
a really clear goal
that goes beyond you.
You have to be intentional about it.
Yeah.
Right.
So, walk me through a little bit about
the different experiences
you've accumulated
and how that goal of yours
played into those different experiences.
Well,
I have to jump back a little bit in time
to dinner table conversations
with my family,
which were usually revolved
around mainly two aspects:
One, was existential risk
like nuclear winter
and climate chaos.
And on the other hand,
things like ion channels in cells
or power microscopy.
How old are you
when you're referring back
to these dinner conversations,
by the way?
I would say, so consciously,
anything between seven and 14, maybe.
Amazing.
So,
and that configured me.
This is kind of like the task
my parents gave us for life.
And it took me a long time
to try and figure out.
A lot of frustration
I had to go through to figure out
how my role could be in that.
And what I could see was always that
money seemed to go
in the wrong direction.
Money never seemed to go
where it should be,
but more where it was exploiting
more planet and people.
And in 2003,
I was part of a meeting
with the head of the central bank
in Germany
and the former head of central bank
from Belgium,
and they were there to introduce
a new complementary currency in Germany.
And I was there to help them
build the software for that.
For political reasons
this never happened,
but it blew my mind anyway.
And what I learned from those people
was that,
the design of a currency
has unintended emergent properties
that then might be negative.
And our current financial system
has enormous
unintended emergent negative properties.
A fiat currency backed by GDP,
we're not going to go into the details,
but is a recipe for disaster.
It is not only an invitation,
but a reward system
for exploitation of planet and people.
So, that's what I've been struggling with
for the past 17 years.
And what have been
more and more aligning
my activities along
to contribute towards a situation
where we can get out of that
gridlock of financial capital
and broaden our perspective
into other forms of capital.
If I look at only financial capital,
I tend to be very, very limited
in my view of the world.
If I look at, let's say,
Ethan Roland's 8 Forms of Capital
like social capital, and material,
and living, and cultural,
and spiritual, intellectual, etc.,
then the equation changes.
And then
you can allow yourself
to act in entirely different ways
because you're not only
after financial capital,
which is important
into get things running
and to create more meaningful things,
but is not enough in itself.
But I have to say, Thomas,
speaking to you,
I feel like I'm speaking to a
somebody who goes to India
for 11 months of the year
doing meditation,
doing very spiritual things
in their day to day life
and also as a job.
But actually,
you're the CEO of a company
that delivers software solutions.
And you're into high tech, right?
And I'm finding this, you know,
intuitively, I'm finding this dissonance
between your profession
and what your upbringing
and the things you're passionate about.
And I'm seeing this dissonance
because I just don't see
enough people like this.
I think it's incredible.
But I don't see enough.
So, thank you for that observation.
You're to the point, absolutely.
But I actually think that
there is no dissonance at all.
It's actually extremely congruent.
If you look at,
especially digital technologies
and also it gets worse
with sustainable
or regenerative technologies,
what you have to do
in order to implement them successfully,
you have to question your status quo.
You have to question your past.
So, if you go into organization
that wants to digitize,
move towards digital transformation
in any meaningful way,
which is part of what we do,
you always have to ask
really fundamental questions.
And this is painful.
Because what it reveals is that
for the past 10, 20, 30, 100 years,
your organization has been
on the wrong track, essentially.
You've been doing things
that look embarrassing
to everyone.
And the only way to deal with this
is to be very clear about yourself.
To have a strong
individual personal foundation.
That's why all of these journeys
have to start with the individual.
And this is why you're totally right.
I don't go to India
to try and be clear about myself.
We've actually developed a framework
to help people do that.
Because that is
of absolute vital basis.
And you can do that
in your everyday life and all the time,
and you can also move that
into your entire organization,
which helps in the decision making.
So, that's what I want to focus on.
Because I think that
I'm on a goal.
I have a personal goal to be intentional.
And I think it's an interesting goal
because my goal is to have a goal.
Right?
I feel that I'm growing up,
I get to have
these really interesting experiences.
I need these really great people,
but I'm trying to become intentional
with my actions.
And what I'm hearing from you is that
we need to have more people
in leadership positions
that are intentional about their goals.
And what do you started out
is by saying,
there are all sorts of goals
and a lot of them are okay,
but you need to be intentional about it.
I mean, when was the last time
you weren't intentional
about your dinner? Right?
So, let's assume
you cook a romantic dinner,
and you never follow a recipe
without knowing what you're cooking.
Right?
Right.
So, usually people don't go on a holiday
unless they know
where they're going and why
and what they're going to experience.
Right?
So, why are people
going through the year, their life,
their next project,
their company,
without really knowing
where they're going?
So, I think there's three,
three important components.
You need to be very clear
where you are
in the vastness of all possibilities.
Incredible, right?
That requires deep,
deep search inside yourself,
to paraphrase the Google thing.
And how do you get there?
Today, with abundance of
both good information,
misinformation,
the things we're experiencing.
In my generation
and our day-to-day lives,
whether it's at university, the military,
in the streets in the city,
we're being pulled
in all sorts of directions.
How can we even begin
to be intentional
about what we're actually feeling?
So, there's this thing called
the Default Mode Network,
which is guiding 90 to 95%
of your decision making every day.
And the default mode network
usually gets coded
in your first seven years of your life.
Wow.
If those people, which we assume
were well intended,
they still coded to you
for an entirely different world.
The rest of your capacity,
your executive network knows what to do,
but your default mode network
pushes you back into behaving
like you always behaved,
and like people were
behaving 50 years ago.
So, you need to clear out
that clutter first.
There are some techniques
of how to do that.
The framework we've developed
is called Roots,
rootsfactor.com,
it's free.
So, anybody can just go there
and sign up.
Amazing.
That helps you with uncluttering,
and then very important,
in developing
your personal first horizon,
which is necessary.
Because once you start uncluttering,
you loose
on the, let's say the hold on,
the current situation of
how things are done in society,
because you're taking things out, right?
You're taking programming out.
So, you need new programming in
and you want to be in charge of that.
If you aren't in charge of that,
you slip into something
called a spiritual emergency.
And a spiritual emergency essentially is,
your brain grabbing onto anything
it can get hold off to make sense of.
This is why
there is so much conspiracy theory
going on at the moment.
Because people
have the strong understanding and notion
and visceral feeling
that the world is falling apart.
And they don't know
how to play a role in that.
And their entire ontology
is breaking down.
They have no epistemology
to make sense of this
and create a new ontology
for themselves.
So, they fill it with conspiracy theory.
So this is very crucial.
So, you have to know where you are,
you have to know where you going,
and then you have to fill
your own coding with that stuff
and start building the infrastructure
for the future.
Right.
It reminds me a little bit of a phenomena
that we see all around us,
but especially, I see in my own country,
that you have in a radical religion
that a lot of the time
from an outsider's observing,
it almost seems like
a lot of the actions
that we choose to take
are sort of to fill a fear
of the unknown.
And we look for solutions.
And even if those solutions
aren't necessarily the right ones,
are not ideal for the world.
If they fill that void,
then we take them in
and we adopt them.
And to me, that feels very dangerous.
And it feels dangerous in an age
where we can have misinformation
spread out very easily.
And when there is
some ambiguity around us
and you have somebody
in a leadership position,
we're seeing it unfold
every single day right now
as we're speaking
with what's happening to the US.
And then we're seeing new ideas
and new information
that is necessarily true,
being adopted by people
that are just looking for answers.
And that is something
that I'm taking with me
as I'm looking to become
potentially is a person who might,
people might want to listen to.
I want to be very conscious
and very responsible
with the messages that I put out
and what's true and what's not true.
That's good.
Maybe you might be familiar
with Robert Keegan's work.
He's a developmental psychologist
and I like using his work,
although it's very similar
to other developmental psychologist work.
He differentiates
between three mindset levels.
He calls it a growth hierarchy
in the adult life.
And it is important to note that
a) every human given enough time
goes through this evolution,
through this hierarchy,
and it's not a power hierarchy.
It's something you grow into,
and it's not something
you can buy yourself into.
So, the first level is
the socialized mindset.
The socialist mindset is defined by
you understanding
the rules of your society
and living by them,
becoming a trusted member,
a working member of your society.
When you step out of that,
and you start questioning
and editing those rules,
you become a self authoring mind.
And this is a discrete step.
This is like the moment in your life
when you started
turning lines into letters, right?
All of a sudden,
you could see these letters
and you could get an idea
of what people were talking about
when they talked about reading.
And then you step out
of your self authoring mind
into what's called,
the self transforming mind.
And now you're looking
at the heuristics yourself.
Authoring mind uses
to edit the socialized mind.
And this is when you start reading,
when you start
putting those letters into words.
And you cannot unlearn that.
And it's a distinct moment,
and it has something to do
with the complexity of your mind.
Wow.
I'm just learning how much I don't know.
And I've always been fascinated
by [--].
Yet again, I have to say that
it inspires me to meet somebody
who is in a high tech.
But within this 20 minute conversation,
we never once talked about
the different projects
that you actually worked on
and the impact
that you've brought with them.
But we talked about more holistically
what is our responsibility.
And one of the things
that I enjoyed most was
that the very first thing
out of the box that you said was,
you know,
you mentioned your goal
and what some of your intentions
into having a positive impact
on the world.
But you mentioned that every person
has a different goal or intention.
And one of the most important things
that we can do for ourselves
is to have that intention,
it's to declutter
and go through that process.
And what you said,
its rootsfactor.com?
Yes.
So, I'm definitely going to check
because that's something that
as I'm growing a little bit older
and maturing myself,
and I see that with my friends as well,
we're looking for that decluttering.
We're saying,
we were fortunate
to have these experiences
and to be learning
with these amazing people.
But now we're going to have to make
some critical choices ourselves.
And with all that clutter,
it becomes very, very difficult.
And so, I'm definitely
very thankful for that.
But, Thomas, I want to thank you
for this wonderful conversation.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Or that somebody
would use to describe you.
Is this have to be a sentence
or can it be in the?
You choose whatever format you want,
but do to have this on record
that in our next 20 minute session,
you're going to be teaching myself
and the audience
how to do a Thai massage,
which we didn't get
to talk about that either.
Yes, I can do that. Yes.
My wife would be happy
because I'll do it on her too.
Okay. So,
I'm...
optimistic beyond reason.
I love that.
Optimistic beyond reason.
I'll try to adopt that
and I'll let you know when I get there.
Thomas, thank you very, very much.
I really appreciate
you taking the time to do this.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
You too.